okay today I'm going to talk to you
about communicable diseases so
communicable disease is a disease which
can be spread between individuals that
just means it can be passed from one
organism to another organism now the
reason why this is the case is because
communicable diseases are to do with
pathogens so pathogens remember
microorganisms small living things which
can cause you harm so there's four
different types of communicable disease
we need to know about for each one we're
going to look at the disease the
pathogen which causes it the symptoms
associated with that disease so how we
know the signs that someone has it how
is it physically spread from one person
to another or one organism from another
to another and what can we do to prevent
the spread of that disease so the first
disease have been look up it's one
called cholera that affects millions of
people across the world so the pathogen
which causes it is caused by bacteria
and particularly bacteria within water
supplies the symptoms associated with
with cholera is diarrhea now this isn't
just an inconvenience this can actually
be life-threatening because if the
diarrhea gets so severe you're actually
losing a lot of water from your body and
it can cause severe dehydration so just
like a previously mentioned it's spread
by contaminated water so lots of people
across the world don't have access to
clean drinking water and they have to
drink water with the cholera bacteria
within within it so that's how it's how
it's spread now the way to prevent this
obviously would be access to clean water
however this isn't always an option for
everyone so if you can't get access to
clean water it's important to boil water
before you drink
kid in order to kill the bacteria
filtering is insufficient
you cannot filter the water because the
bacteria these micro microorganisms are
so small they'll pass through the filter
paper and you can still get cholera from
that water supply so the second disease
we're looking at is tuberculosis
often referred to as TB this is the
second one from the list that is also
caused by bacteria now the symptoms of
TB is coughing and more dangerously lung
damage because these backed the bacteria
in TB affect your lungs so your lungs
can be severely damaged by the
tuberculosis very serious so the way
that it spread from one person to
another is by via the air so it's
airborne so as one person coughs they
eject these bacteria into the air so
it's spread by the air by coughing so
this is why it's so important to cover
your mouth when you cough so not to
spread the disease and the way that this
can be kind of prevented is to avoid
crowded spaces so avoid crowded spaces
would be one way so if the person who
has the disease can stay away from
crowded spaces then they're not going to
be able to spread the disease to the
rest of the population also if you're in
a place that has good ventilation that
will also help as well so we don't have
these airborne bacteria just hanging
around they're constantly moved and
removed so the next two we need to know
about number three is malaria
so malaria the pathogen which causes it
is not a bacteria this time but a
protest so they're just these
single-cell organisms as well so the
symptoms is damage to red blood cells
that's the problem caused so remember
red blood cells carry oxygen around the
body so damaging these red blood cells
can be very very problematic it can also
in certain cases cause liver damage
which is again very serious so how is
malaria spread the way to remember it is
M is for malaria
M is for mosquitoes so mosquitoes a
little insects apologies for my bad
drawing of a mosquito but they're little
insects and what they do is they land on
someone or an organism and it drinks
their blood what event does is it goes
to a different person and the the first
person's blood mixes with the second
person's blood within that blood that's
where the protests are so the protists
the microorganisms are within the blood
that the mosquito drinks the mosquito is
just referred to as a vector because all
the mosquitoes doing is transporting
that pathogen from one person or one
organism to another organism so how do
you prevent this so there's two main
ways first of all mosquito nets now this
just means when you go to bed when you
go to sleep so there's the person on
their bed at the moment without mosquito
net they're exposed so a mosquito net
it's just a real thin meshed net that
goes over your bed that stops the
mosquitos being able to get in another
one nice and simple is just bug
repellent so if you've got some kind of
repellent that would help as well okay
the final one that we need to know about
is the only example
that is within plants and this one is
called Solara ash dieback now we have a
different pathogen for this one because
this one here is actually caused by a
fungus which grows on the branches of
trees grows on the branches just like
this okay
so the symptoms the problem that we that
we have occurring within the the trees
is leaf loss and bark lesions that just
means we have these kind of big holes
and damage to the bark itself caused by
that fungus now the way that it gets
transported from one tree to another or
one organism to another is by wind so
it's kind of airborne so let's say I've
got one branch here of one tree and
here's another branch here when the wind
blows that some of those funke some of
the fungus is transported across and can
then go and infect this tree here so how
can we get rid of this so the the way to
prevent this is to remove and replace
basically take out remove any infected
trees immediately so let's say if a
couple of these trees here or just one
of these trees is one which is infected
like this one here it's important just
to cut it down and remove it instantly
so the other ones don't get infected as
well okay so those are the four
different communicable diseases that we
need to know about thank you